parliament's has been on holiday for six
weeks but Boris Johnson and his aides
have been working flat outs to make good
on their vow that brexit will happen by
November with or without any agreed plan
with the European Union to show our
friends in Brussels that we are united
in our purpose MPs should vote with the
government against Corbin's pointless
delay I want everybody to know there are
no circumstances in which I will ask
Brussels to delay but since he has a
majority of just one in Parliament it
doesn't take many rebels from his own
Conservative Party to cause him huge
problems and they are so concerned about
a No Deal brexit that they're ignoring
threats to kick them out of the
parliamentary party and it seems at
least some will back a plan to order the
government to delay brexit yet again
I've decided that the interests of my
constituents are best represented by
outlining the perils of No Deal and
continuing to do what I've done since
2016 which is urged the government to
make a deal so that we leave the EU in
the best possible way both for the UK
and the EU if they succeed Johnson has a
number of options and they are all
incendiary you could either choose to
ignore the will of parliament and push
on with rex it anyway and face
accusations of being dictatorial or more
likely he could call a national election
which would in effect become a second
referendum on brexit it's the big
fundamental calculation that summoned
Boris Johnson's camper making is that
currently he has the opportunity to
unite supporters of brexit under one
ticket under the Boris Johnson ticket
while the remain parties the Liberal
Democrats the Labour Party the Green
Party the nationalist parties remain
completely divided and that's the big
fundamental calculation that summoned
Boris Johnson's camera making whether or
not that will pay off it remains to be
seen
all this means there is enormous
pressure to on the main opposition
leader Jeremy Corbyn much less
personally popular than Johnson on
Monday the former Labour Prime Minister
Tony Blair notably failed to offer
Corbin his own backing in backing away
from the idea of himself as a caretaker
Prime Minister Jeremy Corbyn is behave
responsibly and if he continues to put
country first he will benefit the
country and himself he can now play a
decisive role in how brexit develops but
you should see an election before
braixen is decided for the elephant trap
that it is everyone here is gearing up
for feels like one of the most important
moments in modern British political
history which will help determine
whether brexit will happen at all and if
so under what terms for some time now
Parliament and in particular the
Conservative Party have been tearing
themselves to pieces
maybe this eventually will be the
defining moments the EU is sitting and
waiting watching for any peace of
movements to clarify what will happen
they like everyone else want an end to
all this lawrence lee al jazeera in
london